hier les femmes mohawk formaient le gros
du cortège était même mise de l'avant
lorsque le barrage ferroviaire a été
levée à kahnawake que l'ady gil s'est
transportée au pied du pont mercier
jusque là pourtant pendant ces
pourparlers entre les chefs héréditaire
ou est souhaitaient les conseils de
bande les gouvernements peu de femmes
autochtones ont pris la parole
alors quel est leur rôle leur pouvoir au
sein de leurs communautés j'en discute
avec mélissa mollen du puits elle est
coorganisatrice de haider no more et
militante innu pourquoi madame anna
merci d'être avec nous alors pourquoi
les femmes autochtones ont-elles pris
les devants hier pourquoi hier qu'elle
envoyait mais c'est ce que mon ignore
c'est qu'il ya un système matriarcal
mais même matriarcale c'est très
difficile à dire parce que c'est plutôt
matrilinéaire parce que quand on parle
de matriarcat on parle de pouvoir un
pouvoir aux hommes pouvoir aux femmes
alors que le système matrilinéaire cd
système d'héritage qui est porté par les
femmes mais les pouvoirs sont partagés
entre les hommes et les femmes donc on
voyait le barrage est érigée c'était les
hommes qui étaient là c'était d'ailleurs
un rôle un peu de voir mais dans la
décision de la communauté dans la
pratique traditionnelle
les femmes ont un rôle extrêmement
important d'ailleurs on a pu le voir
pendant la crise d'oka pendant les deux
cent soixante dix ans de résistance
d'alanis obomsawin on voit un moment
donné une intervention d'un des hommes
qui est arrêté par une femme qui dit
votre calme parce que ce rôle d
d'égalité le
et des fois difficile les hommes vont
être très passionné bon je te voir des
chefs de guerre ou des chefs d' économie
traditionnellement et les femmes elles
géraient la communauté donc leur parler
du sortant est ce que votre avis toutes
les décisions sont prises comme ça en
consultation entre hommes et femmes au
sein des instances de pouvoir je pense
pas qu'un loyer par exemple parce que la
décision d'ériger une barricade
ferroviaire puis de la levée a été prise
en consultation avec les femmes je pense
qu'il ya eu un réflexe par rapport à la
seule vérité avec les oueds souhaité
haine qui a beaucoup été porté par les
femmes dans la mobilisation parce que
les femmes vont être les premières à
vouloir défendre la communauté
elles sont les maires les grands mères
elles voient ce qui se passe directement
au taux du campement habituellement ou
de la communauté mais l'apport des
hommes étaient aussi importants ce qui a
été détruit par la loi sur les indiens
du 176 c'était justement ces modèles de
partage des pouvoirs plutôt des
responsabilités du leadership parce
qu'on est les européens n'étaient pas
habitués de voir des femmes décidées
prendre parole même des fois j'entendais
des histoires comme quoi on aux herbes
et ils ont peur des femmes c'est pour ça
qu'ils veulent pas qu'elles soient
présentes quand il ya des ponts par les
eaux des ententes d'ailleurs il pourquoi
ils sont pas avec eux pour le voyage
les premiers voyages donc c'était même
que celui ils sont vraiment pas de leur
femme ou sont effrayés par le rôle qui
est juste celui traditionnel mais gênés
dans leur rôles traditionnels est ce que
les femmes autochtones ont tendance à
appuyer des actions comme des barrages
ferroviaire oh oui mais je sais c'est
souvent malheureusement
la dernière comment choisir dernières
ressources que l'on a
parce que les femmes autochtones vont
toujours favorisé puis dans toutes les
nations que j'ai vu favoriser le
dialogue peut importe qu est-ce que
c'est parce qu'on veut la cohésion
sociale
c'est une question de survie depuis des
milliers d'années cependant les
dernières centaines d'années on s'entend
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui ne pas écouter
donc pour tirer l'oreille
il faut attirer l'attention et un blocus
ferroviaire pacifique mais pas passif
est souvent la meilleure manière
d'attirer l'attention mais dit on vous
entend vous bien sûr vous avez fondé à
raison nos morts au québec donc on
entend des femmes autochtones dans leurs
prises de paroles prendre la parole mais
pourquoi par exemple qu'elle a wag et
pourquoi est ce que dans ce mouvement
qui de barrage ferroviaire pourquoi est
ce qu'on les a pas vus prendre la parole
expliquer pourquoi elle appuyait cela
mais ce que mon défaut de la misère à
comprendre c'est qu'on n'est pas non
plus dans des formes de leadership qui
aiment prendre le devant
souvent même que c'est vu comme un poids
qui est de prendre parole alors que
c'est valoriser dans une culture euros
centre et nord américains très tournée
vers les médias
le leadership est supposé d'être
beaucoup plus humble beaucoup moins
portée va prendre le devant et laisser
la parole aux autres ce qui est un peu
bizarre parce qu'avec haydn au moins
nous on faisait une coorganisation en
plusieurs voix de femmes
mais le modèle étant ce qu'il est
certaines personnes ont pris plus de
présence dans les médias mais c'est vu
comme une responsabilité donc j'ai pas
la permission de parler à tout vent je
dois consulter ma communauté m'assurer
que je porte bien la voix des autres
donc c'est souvent plus comme une
responsabilité et un comme un peu plus
comme un être porteur de la parole des
autres
alors les femmes vont être beaucoup plus
occupé à écouter la communauté qu'à
vouloir prendre le micro et parler
devant tout le monde me diriez vous que
dans la communauté autochtone celle que
vous connaissez la morale sont d'autres
lino aussi les femmes sont les égales
des hommes à leysin les femmes sont
extrêmement présents moi c'est le modèle
d'ailleurs que historiquement j'ai vu en
grandissant et d'ailleurs je comprenais
pas tout le temps le manque de présence
des grands mères
manque de prise de parole parce que les
femmes étaient tellement actif au niveau
communautaire au niveau du conseil de
bande
mais dans certains rôles à cause de
l'interaction avec le gouvernement comme
les chefs les conseillers sur ans
étaient des hommes parce que c'était un
peu ce qui était demandé
mais de plus en plus les femmes prennent
des rôles auprès des conseils de bande
mais ont des rôles extrêmement actif au
niveau de la communauté
d'ailleurs on se faisait souvent la
farce et quand ça va mal les premières
nations ce mobilisme quand ça va
vraiment mal c'est les femmes des
premières nations qui se mobilisent on
l'a vu dans 1990 on l'a vu avec un bon
moment en 2012 86 à chris doyle et
fiscaux est justement un des modèles
féminins qui m'a le plus inspirée elle
hengelbrock était à l'avant mais elle
avait cette responsabilité-là de sa
communauté 2012 on a porté la voix et
leurs vins
on a vu les femmes cheffes de oued
souhaitait se faire arrêter se faire
arracher du territoire et ça c'est une
image qui a été gravé dans nos dans nos
assez fortement
il ya eu aussi cette enquête nationale
sur les femmes autochtones disparues ou
assassinées bon les femmes autochtones
sont peut-être les égales de lors de
leurs camarades masculins en mettant
beaucoup de violence contre les femmes
au milieu autochtone et le titre du
rapport s'était réclamé notre pouvoir
est notre place dans la société blanche
mais au sein de votre communauté vous
estimez que cette place vous avez la
place que vous méritez le rôle doit être
réparé il faut pas oublier que les
pensionnats quelle est la loi sur les
indiens qui a beaucoup eu de système qui
ont été mis en place de forces dans nos
communautés qui ont détruit notre rôle
traditionnel notre présence est avec moi
personnellement avec un moment j'ai
retrouvé cette place traditionnelle là
mais c'est une place qui peut pas se
faire sans la présence des hommes donc
nos formes à nous de féminisme inclut
beaucoup la présence des hommes et des
enfants des aînés sas c'est une
responsabilité de porter la voix de tous
parce qu'on on peut pas être guéri
si quelqu'un d'autre est malade dans la
communauté donc on essaie vraiment de
faire la guérison des pensionnats la
guérison
des injustices justement de s'être fait
arracher au territoire de perte de
langues et ça s'est souvent porté par
les femmes parce que c'est d'être du
travail qui rémunérés et qui porté par
la passion des femmes à vouloir aider la
communauté à vouloir porter la
communauté et pendant un bon moment une
zone on leur demandait mais pourquoi
vous n'êtes pas au devant et les animaux
suis pas devant ma femme je suis pas
derrière elle
je suis avec elle alors c'était de
respecter si nous nous responsabilité
commune donc on protège l'eau on protège
la communauté et les sommes qu'on a pu
voir aux barricades protéger le
territoire
mélissa mollen dupuis merci beaucoup
nous avoir éclairé sur tout ça merci
pour tes quoi